avec hélène frade bien sûr bonjour allen
bon jour n'abîme pas de 2 lundi de
pâques pour nous pas de jours fériés en
tout cas à la une de la presse d'abord
ces heurts qui ont opposé hier des
palestiniens à la police israélienne sur
l'esplanade des mosquées à jérusalem
après la violente répression de vendredi
qui a fait 150 morts les affrontements
150 blessés pardonnez moi merci
christophe c'est les affrontements
d'hier ont de nouveau fait 19 blessés
donc côté palestinien le jerusalem post
accusent les manifestants de perturber
le mois saint d'attaqué est la liberté
de culte mais aussi le parti arabe
israélien ram qui a décidé de suspendre
sa participation à la coalition
gouvernementale de naftali bennet de
souffler sur les braises de chercher à
tirer profit un profil politique de ces
affrontements cette confrontation entre
palestiniens et israéliens dans la
vieille ville de jérusalem fait
également la une ce matin d'al arabi al
jadid d'après le quotidien panarabe de
londres l'appel au calme lancé à la fois
par l'egypte et le qatar aura reçu une
fin de non recevoir de la part des
forces israéliennes accusées d'avoir
lancé je cite une nouvelle agression
contre les fidèles de la mosquée al aqsa
pour permettre aux colons israéliens dix
entrées par effraction pour arab news la
violence de ces derniers jours à
jérusalem serait surtout liée en réalité
à l'injustice fondamentale je cite de
l'occupation les israéliens éduquer
clairvoyant doivent prendre conscience
que l'occupation illégale des terres
palestiniennes
la suppression indéfinie et injuste des
droits des palestiniens choron et
discrédite les israéliens eux-mêmes
dénonce le quotidien saoudien à la une
de la presse à travers le monde
également ce matin la suite des combats
marioupol dans l'est de l'ukraine où les
soldats à siéger assure vouloir
combattre jusqu'au bout pour les seules
deux ukrainiens marioupol est devenue le
symbole de la résistance de la nation à
l'invasion russe d'après le financial
times qui explique damien que la capture
de la ville d'onnaing est un énorme coup
de pouce à la campagne de vladimir
poutine en permettant à ses troupes
d'achever le pont terrestre qu'elle
tente d'établir depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant entre le sud entre
la crimée et les villes qu'elles sont en
train de et dans le sud de l'ukraine une
victoire qui libère est également des
ressources pour l'offensive attendue de
moscou dans le donbass que le président
ukrainien accuse la russie de chercher à
détruire je le cite dans une interview
qui a été diffusé hier volodymyr
zelensky a par ailleurs évoqué la
possibilité future d'une future visite
de joe biden qui a utilisé on s'en
souvient la semaine dernière le mot
génocide pour désigner les exactions des
soldats russes en ukraine contrairement
à emmanuel macron le président français
estime lui que l'emploi de ce mot
génocide doit être qualifié je le cite
par des juristes et non par les
politiques un refuge et très blessant
par le président ukrainien qui invite
également le président français à venir
constater la réalité sur place il
viendra et il verra et je suis sûr qu'il
comprendra a déclaré vladimir zelensky
cité par l'ops et on verra ce seront à
kiev emmanuel macron actuellement en
pleine campagne de l'autre le tour ici
pour la présidentielle et qui tente de
rallier les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon ont appelé par le patron d'ea
soumis à ne pas donner je le cite une
seule voix à marine le pen les militants
du mouvement étaient consultés ce
week-end sur leur choix pour ce second
tour selon cette consultation plus de 37
et demi pour cent disent qu'ils voteront
blanc au second tour dimanche prochain
un peu moins de 33 et demi pour cent
disent qu'ils voteront pour emmanuel
macron et 29 pour cent comptent
s'abstenir noter que l'option d'un vote
en faveur de marine le pen n'était pas
proposé la patronne du rassemblement
national qui est accusé dans un rapport
de l'office antifraude de l'union
européenne relayé par mediapart d'avoir
personnellement détourné près de 140000
euros d'argent public du parlement de
strasbourg lorsqu'elle est est
eurodéputé c'est à dire entre 2004 et
2010 est sollicité par mediapart
l'avocat de la candidate a dénoncé je le
cite la coïncidence de la publication de
cette enquête et cette campagne de
l'entré deux tours pour les
présidentielles campagne suivi de très
près par la presse étrangère le
financial times se projettent même déjà
à damien dans la presse second tour et
il prédit que si emmanuel macron gagner
il serait alors en position de force
pour faire avancer ses plans ambitieux
je cite pour la france et l'union
européenne mais que si marine le pen
l'emportent alors ce sera un séisme
politique équivalent d'après le journal
aubrée excité à l'élection de donald
trump en 2016 d'après le quotidien
britannique la victoire de cette
fervente nationaliste et eurosceptique
remettrait en question l'avenir de l'ue
tandis que son programme basé sur
l'immigration la dénonciation de
l'immigration et l'islam menacerait je
cite la stabilité sociale de la france
elle annonce qu'il part là dessus avant
de vous dirai demain damien je vous
propose de revenir du côté de la presse
française qui fait état figurez-vous de
la disparition ce week-end de shoot si
cela part géant des flandres de 8 kg
tout de même à dont le nom le prénom
signifie petit bisou en alsacien se
trouve être la mascotte du marché de
cold de colmar qui est une ville dans
l'est de la france alors le maire de la
ville a annoncé le dépôt d'une plainte
et prévenu ses administrés qu'un nouveau
spécimen sera mis été mises à
disposition pour le plaisir des petits
et des grands espérons tout de même un
cochon ci sera bientôt de retour et
qu'il n'est pas passé à la casserole de
petit lapin de 8 kg faut une grosse
casserole cas merci beaucoup elle a une
phrase mer